viel gibt es hier nicht mehr eine kirche
eine bushaltestelle ein paar gänse als
sündenbock geht es wie vielen dörfern in
brandenburg ihre zeit scheint langsam
aber unaufhaltsam zu ende zu gehen
die verbliebenen knapp 200 bewohner
resigniert wir wollen hier noch bleiben
wenn kaum arbeiten union leute ziehen
weg
ich habe meinen kindern auch gesagt
nicht erfüllt werden und bekannte dich
festhalten
so traurig das ist doch rettung naht in
brandenburg hat man den dorf kamera
erfunden
hans jürgen weber ist jetzt so was wie
der animateur von altendorf
das ist kein trockener verwaltungsjobs
wie der des ortsvorstehers diva kann
machen was er will
hauptsache er bringt wieder leben in
sein dorf dafür erhalte 400 euro pro
monat
natürlich möchte ich durch mein
persönliches beispiel menschen aus dem
dorf animieren sich zu bewegen wieder
aktiv zu werden und für unser elkendorf
was zu tun dort kamera haben visionen
der rüstige rentner zum beispiel setzt
auf eine bislang ungenutzte attraktion
in der unmittelbaren umgebung
wir haben hier eine buchen weil der mit
dem lescaut titel ausgezeichnet ist
weltnaturerbe
um es ganz deutlich zu machen wir
spielen in einer liga mit dem grand
canyon
der grand canyon und die buchenwälder
von altkunden dorf das ist doch eine
goldgrube aus der man was machen kann
das ist eine chance verkünden dorf so
eine chance kriegen wir nie wieder
und da muss man jetzt ran und das habe
ich gemacht
hans jürgen weber ist stolz darauf einer
der ersten dorf kümmerer in brandenburg
zu sein
im rathaus der übergeordneten stadt
dritter voller selbstbewusstsein auf er
will genehmigungen und geld und er lässt
nicht locker bis er bekommt was er will
im rathaus hat man sich mittlerweile an
den hartnäckigen dorf kümmerer gewöhnt
findet das ganze irgendwie sogar gut
ich denke er kann die fäden zusammen
führen in diesem ort er kann beispiel
geben
ja und er kann kontakte knüpfen und
damit den leuten die ihm zur seite
stehen aus seinem heimatverein oder wie
gesagt aus der kirchengemeinde dass er
da ja wahrscheinlich erste schritte tut
das eher ziele setzt und man auf diese
ziele hinaus arbeitet der engagierte
dorf kümmerer scheint auch die ersten
altkunden dörfer wachgerüttelt zu haben
macht druck er kümmert sich viel drauf
um dem weltnaturerbe hat er sich darum
gekümmert also dass wir eben damit
chancen haben und dass eben bei könnten
darauf das tor zum weltnaturerbe wird
es ist schon er hat sich schon gekümmert
und zwar richtig
140000 euro für ein neues tourismus
zentrum und den ersten neuen
arbeitsplatz den hat er dorf kamera auch
schon geschaffen
der ehemalige arbeitslose dagobert
walter ist jetzt verantwortlich für den
infopunkt besonders stolz ist er auf das
geplante café denn sowas gibt es bisher
nicht in ihrem dorf
küchenzeile
im sommer kommen die leute unterkommen
wird von ihrem rundgang an unseren
weltnaturerbe sich auch mal durst auf
einer tasse kaffee und wasser und so
können wir sie gut versorgen damit im
zuständigen landesministerium ist man
mit den dorfkern sehr zufrieden
8 gibt es bisher in ganz brandenburg und
vielleicht gelingt es dem einen oder
anderen tatsächlich die landflucht zu
stoppen
vor allem kleine dörfer brauchen
angesichts des demografischen wandels
neue impulse für wirtschaftliche
entwicklung und das muss aus dem ort
heraus entstehen und da haben wir im
dorf kamera die frau gemerkt dass wenn
ein einzelner im dorf wirklich ideen
aufgreift diskussion anstößt menschen
begeistert und mitreißt dann können vor
einem sozialunternehmen entstehen
die neue struktur staffel eventuell auch
arbeitsplätze und diesen ort attraktiv
machen
hans jürgen weber hat schon längst das
nächste projekt im blick der alte
kirchturm der wäre doch eine prima
aussichtsplattform
dann könnten die neuen touristen
altkunden dorf und seinen unesco
prämierten buchenwald auch von oben
genießen